as 2020 democrats descend on iowa to
slam president Trump frontrunner Joe
Biden is doing his best to rebound from
a bruising debate before me what's
included a showdown with Kamala Harris
over his past position on race were you
prepared for them to come after you
I was prepared him to come after me but
I wasn't prepared for the person coming
at me the way she came out she knew beau
she knows me I don't know anyway I but
here's the deal what I do know and it's
a good in the bad news the American
people think they know me and they know
me the former VP also revealin how he
plans to take down President Trump had
he beat him I beat him by just pointing
out Who I am and who he is and what were
for and what he's against this guy is a
divider in chief
this guy is acting with racist policies
this guy is moving to chin today's forum
at hate to split that's the only way he
can be sustained himself the idea that
I'd be intimidated by Donald Trump he's
the bully that I knew my whole life he's
the bully that I've always stood up to
he's the bully used to make fun when I
was a kid in a stutter and I'd smacked
him in the mouth one he talks a tougher
game but when Kamala Harris had him
against the ropes he's essentially said
No Mas nobody time ran out you know what
it's in this that it's very interesting
Lawrence because in that interview he
gave the impression that he really
wasn't ready to be challenged in that
way and if that's true boy that's big
trouble because he should have known
that as the front-runner there were long
knives ready for him that's how other
people were going to rise and challenge
him as the front-runner that's exactly
what Kamala Harris did she took a man in
the stage and it's the reason why we've
seen her jump ahead in the polls I think
what you're seeing there is he's trying
to strike the right tone he doesn't want
to be too aggressive in trying to take
her out and he says he's not gonna play
that game maybe he can have his
surrogates his his aides you know plant
stories and go after as in that fashion
but I think he wants to remain as if
he's above the fray that he's the
front-runner John he wants to remain
above the fray until huge cusers of the
president of being essentially racist I
mean he pretty much said it right there
right and so is this his strategy just
target say all the supporters the
president everybody's supposed Trump
they're just faces man I mean you're
playing Trump's game so you know I think
Trump became president because he was
out there throwing haymakers you know
and and I think they think that's how
they're gonna beat him but I don't
really think that's how you beat him I
think you're just playing his ballgame
when you step into that he loves that
and so now Biden's having Hamaker stone
at him you wouldn't have seen that
in the past couple of elections nobody
talk like that no but you might smacking
something in the mouth or or anything
like that but uh you know it looks like
to me Biden that said this earlier he's
been left as then he can't go it's a
it's in his nature to go that left but
he's kind of out of his comfort zone
because he's happened to go that left to
be able to have the same conversation
everybody else's happened I think he
sort of said you know what I'm not as
far left as everybody else is and I'm
the one who's been in Washington I know
how to get things done I'm just gonna
marinate where I am right now I think he
was just sort of sitting there staying
in his Lane there's no way he can run as
an outsider how long has he been in
Washington so if he runs on saying I've
got this place figured out I can get
things done I'm the one who's looking
forward to the general election to try
to beat Donald Trump rather than dealing
with all of this then maybe he's he's
he's it's straight court he addresses
some of the politics when it comes to
the progressive wing in AOA I think we
have some sound let's take a look
80% of your party says it's center-left
I am sending them farther left is
getting more attention it's getting
amplified yes look there's a disconnect
look it's set her left that's where I am
where it's not is way left by the way I
think I think Acacio Cortez is a
brilliant bright woman but she won a
primary that in the general election
fights who won mainstream Democrats who
are very progressive on social issues
and very strong on education health care
look my North Star is the middle class
when the middle class does well
everybody does well Tammy if that's the
case then why is he flip-flopping on
everything well I think what people are
missing is that his reaction in and of
itself to what miss Harris did reminds
you that there's never been a real
competitive primary for either party
first one was with with Trump and now
this one is that he didn't expect to be
held accountable he didn't expect
someone else in that lineup to say
something harsh or to maybe tell the
truth or what they saw is the truth
because gosh they know each other this
reveals to everyone the fact that this
had been a there's been kind of a sham
from the beginning which is what all
Americans in both parties have rejected
and haven't liked this idea that this is
pre-arranged that he's the one who's
supposed to get it and he's got that
kind of demeanor now I agree the the
Democratic voter is not the the Democrat
of the liberal on Twitter it is someone
who's much more quiet and who's watching
but then if if that is the case then he
should have no problem but what he knows
is that Kamala Harris is going to cast
herself as that so he knows he's not
running against a Sandy Ocasio Cortez
he's running against you know Kamala
Harris who's going to shift no one's
going to be running in the end in the
general as on the left but they've got
to pander in a certain way so I think
Joe Biden and then just ultimately what
people don't like is and I don't think
he understands the irony of complaining
about Trump being the divider and then
trying to you know disembowel him with
his you know he's a racist it I punch
these guys in the mouth everybody know
he wants that and especially when it's
not natural when it's when it's when
you're trying to play a role in a
certain I don't think it's not natural
given some of the statements Trump is
made on race but I think the bigger
point right now is that we got another
debate in three weeks mm-hmm and so
you're gonna have a higher bar and it's
going to be tough again for Joe Biden
because he looked bad coming out of that
debate and other people made up ground
so people are going to be looking to
punch again at Joe Biden he better
figure out how to deal with this
my sense is though that Joe Biden
claimed at this moment a me is that he's
the most electable Democrat running
against them even even at this moment
remember he still is in the lead I mean
there's some polls that have I think
it's Elizabeth Warren Bernice and I'm
sorry Bernie Sanders within five points
but we but still that's that's
misleading because of course this is
going state-by-state you're looking at
most of this is like national approval
it's going to show very differently as
they go into each state for the
primaries and then it is the debates are
this is still going to matter real quick
how do you feel about Kamala's reversal
when it comes to the bustling issue the
back-and-forth to me you know I think
that there's a lot of pressure from the
left is all of you guys have been saying
on the panel today but to my mind the
only way we've made progress on civil
rights in this country is by dealing
with people who have racist views trying
to work something out and make steady
progress that has taken us to what I
think is the best point in American
history for people of color so what I
think is pretty shady that she made it a
central issue and then reversed on it
for the American people it's it seemed
it was reversed she has the same no no
now I'm busing in terms of things we
should have incentives to promote school
position